stochastic progressive photo mapping
what is this thing about well you would
need an infinite amount of photons to
ensure consistency you cannot do that
but what you could do is that you could
from time to time generate a new photo
map and use that and this means
discarding previous samples and creating
new ones so we start out with a regular
ray tracing pass that we call I pass and
we use this photo map that we have and
then we generate a new photon map and
then we are going to use that from the
next pass there's also an addition and
you start out with bigger photons so to
say and the size or the radius of these
photons would shrink in time why is this
useful
well because you have practically an
infinite number of photons and you can
see how the rendered image evolves over
time with progressive photo mapping so
this method is consistent this is a big
deal because you can make photo mapping
consistent in practical cases so this is
our previous scene with heavy SDS
transport and you can see how it
converges in the first ten minutes of
the rendering process with sv PM
another set of results with the
classical algorithms that we all know
and love and you can see that photo
mapping kind of works you don't have
higher frequency noise but you can see
that it over blurs many of the important
features of the image and this is the
result with ppm much sharper images
slightly more noise but it is
practically consistent what about this
difficult previous scene with lots of
SDS transport well for our mapping kind
of worked but it again over blurred many
of the important features progressive
photo mapping takes care of this you can
read the papers here so s ppm doesn't
just render SDS light paths but it does
it efficiently it is a wonderful
previewing algorithm so you can just
fire it up and in a matter of seconds
you can get a good idea on how your
scene actually is going to look like
however if you set the starting radius
to a setting that's too high then you're
gonna have large photons for the longest
time and this means that the image will
be again over blurred for a very long
time in the rendering process however if
you set it for too low it will be a very
sharp image but it will take a very long
time to fill the image so as you can see
this is a more complex technique that
can possibly outperform the algorithms
that you have previously seen but this
comes at a cost
this is a more complex algorithm this is
slightly more difficult to implement and
it has more parameters than previous
methods you can see that this is not
like the large mutation probability with
metropolis light transport if you set up
one of the parameters incorrectly you
may have to wait for way too long and if
you set up a simple photon mapper not as
ppm a simple photo mapper incorrectly
you may even get an incorrect image
because you don't have enough photons at
the most important regions of the image
this work was created by Toshi aha
chisca
and his colleagues and it's a brilliant
piece of work